gamespot got the exciting chance to dive
into sumaru early and take a look at the
new characters dendro element and
explorable lands for a test drive so
let's take a look at what you should
know about genji impact's massive 3.0
update and the lush lands of sumeru
first whatever you do don't rush sumeru
it's not going anywhere as a matter of
fact the desert areas as of now are
still time gated similar to what we saw
with the release of separate islands in
inazuma so take your time with the
content what i would focus on is finding
the essentials first focus farm
dendroculus if you want to have the
dendro traveler powered up quickly
unlock the dendro artifacts domain near
the chasm and maybe for materials as you
need for specific characters otherwise
don't pick sumaru's puzzles and loot
clean this area is beautiful and speed
running through it is almost a
disservice to it i'll go into the actual
lands of sumeru later in the video but
first we got a hands-on preview a week
ahead of time on the two brand new
characters carla the junior forest
ranger previously seen in genjen comics
and al tignari although they chose to
pronounce it as tainari in game this is
my master
forest watch your tinari tainari is a
dendroburst dps and was a blast to play
unfortunately my account had him at
constellation 6 with trash artifacts so
it wasn't the most relatable tainari but
given the right teams he has a chance to
absolutely demolish enemies with ease
his weapon of choice is a bow and arrow
with charged shots that follow up with
homing attacks to unleash high dendro
damage his skill tosses out a noxious
cloud in front of his opponents doing
dendro damage and causing them to get
confused and attack in random directions
his ultimate unleashes a delayed barrage
of homing arrows that do high damage and
can take down targets quickly his
skill's passive though allows any
follow-up charged shots to be shot much
more quickly and he can hold this
passive into his next barrage making him
a deadly ranged burst dps
one with the farts
[Music]
carle is a dendro support character who
wields a bone arrow as well as her main
weapon her skill is a large boomerang
that is tossed out and deals dendro
damage on cast and on return and summons
a ring of dendro around the character
and her burst creates a large dendro
explosion in a small area
now let's talk about the new element to
get an impact dendro this element brings
a lot to the table and has opened a lot
of doors for older characters who are
previously not considered meta so this
update will shake things up for invested
players
so how does dendro interact with other
elements first dendro does not react
with geo or animo
which is bad for geo but this can be
beneficial for animo actually
specifically for bursts that absorb
other elements which can create large
areas of fast supplying elements that
react to dendro separately and create
some extremely strong teams second it
doesn't react with cryo although it can
co-exist at the same time with cryo
which sometimes can keep dendro applied
on the enemy for a longer time which is
useful in certain teams
pyro and dendro is an old reaction
that's fairly straightforward it creates
burning which does damage over time
hydro and electro though are where
things get interesting and i'll show
examples of some teams that incorporate
each type of reaction applying hydro and
dendro causes bloom once you've dropped
a bloom seed it can react again with two
more elements electro and pyro electro
causes hyper bloom and sends damaging
homing attacks at your enemy
and hitting a seed with pyro instead
causes burgeon an explosion that does
immediate damage in a small area
[Music]
now for electro applying it to an enemy
with dendro causes quicken seen with
this green lightning a state that has
the ability to boost damage further for
either element hitting quickened enemies
with a follow-up electro attack causes
aggravate which is bonus damage for
electro attacks
and hitting quicken enemies with dendro
attacks causes spread which is bonus
damage for dendro attacks
[Music]
these reactions can give new life to
older characters such as lisa and toma
giving them a chance to be used as
specialized dendro teams which is an
awesome way to buff characters and shake
up the meta without directly changing
the characters themselves
small other updates are making their way
as well such as elemental resonances
like dendro boosting elemental mastery
by a flat amount and double hydro
switched from healing bonus to hp
instead they are also adding multiple
older artifact domains to the strongbox
for you to turn in your fodder into
better sets the lands of sumeru itself
consist of multiple beautiful biomes
cities and villages as secrets to
uncover with a blight taking over
portions of the map that only vision
holders can traverse through it's your
job to clear these areas and help the
people of sumeru subaru also has more
underground exploration as well with the
maze of tunnels you can discover new
enemies new quests new materials to
gather all orchestrated by a beautiful
soundtrack will keep you enthralled in
the land of sumeru
let us know what you're most excited
about in the massive sumaru update and
for all things gaming keep it here on
gamespot
[Music]
you